microsoft and windows are basically
synonymous
as the bulk of microsoft's massive
success can be explained by the easy to
use and affordable operating system
used around the world consequently most
of us have become used to a new windows
version coming out
every couple of years however it's been
nearly six years since windows 10 came
out
and we haven't heard anything about the
next version of windows
so here's why microsoft refuses to make
windows 11.
starting off making an operating system
is not easy
it requires years of development testing
and optimization
though microsoft has gone relatively
good at developing operating systems
over the years
it nonetheless takes a lot of manpower
which costs a lot of money
the work and financial investment would
be worth it if the end product was at
least stellar
but this too is not the case nowadays
technology advances at such a fast rate
that by the time microsoft finishes
development of an operating system
the new os is already a couple of years
behind when it comes out
if microsoft were to set out on creating
the next os right after the launch of
the first os
this gets them stuck in a loop of
endlessly creating new operating systems
that are never truly up to date
meanwhile microsoft's marketing
department
also has to work really hard at
promoting the new windows
they have to meet with manufacturers
like dell and hp
and create new deals to incorporate the
new operating system into their upcoming
machines
they also have to create promotional
material in order to communicate to
customers that there is a new os
available as you can see this cycle
constantly constrains a significant
amount of microsoft's development and
marketing team
to windows this wouldn't be a problem if
these efforts were at least rewarded
with large revenues
and profits however this isn't the case
don't get me wrong here microsoft's
operating system sells extremely well
and makes microsoft billions of dollars
but
did microsoft really need to develop a
new operating system to retain this
market
well the answer is no here's the thing
since 2000 the consumer pc industry has
radically changed to favor ease of use
gone are the days where you bought
windows licenses separately at best buy
or transferred over your old windows
license onto your new computer
unless you're building your own pc which
is a very very small portion of the pc
industry
you likely don't even think about the
operating system as a separate product
for the average customer whether
corporate or individual
you buy a computer or laptop and it just
works
in other words the vast majority of
revenue from windows comes from computer
manufacturers licensing windows from
microsoft
as opposed to individual customers
buying licenses straight from microsoft
aside from this computers are lasting
longer than ever before
and operating systems are more stable
than ever before
so the average customer is unlikely to
upgrade their os
or computer just because a new windows
came out
they might be intrigued by the new
operating system but chances are
they're just going to wait until the
next time they buy a computer to upgrade
their os
at the same time a lack of a new
operating system isn't going to deter a
customer from buying a new computer
thus stopping development of windows was
not only going to save microsoft
billions in terms of research and
marketing but it wasn't really going to
affect their top line
either another major area in which
microsoft would save a lot of money and
headache is within their support
division
you see before settling on windows 10
microsoft would have to continuously
support
older versions of windows as well
oftentimes
this consisted of developing patches for
various issues on
older versions of windows which had
already been fixed in the newer versions
clearly this was a further inefficient
use of manpower
giving microsoft more reason to ditch
operating system development
something to keep in mind though is that
stopping development of new operating
systems
doesn't mean that microsoft couldn't
keep updating their current operating
system
and this is precisely what they have
been doing for the past couple of years
as we all know every now and then we'll
get a notification
that there is an update available and we
can choose to update the next time we
shut down
these updates don't add anything major
like a new toolbar
or start menu rather they're mostly
related to optimization
and reducing the frequency of the blue
screen of death and so on
considering that windows has basically
evolved to its final form
anyways this hasn't been that big of a
deal for most users
anyways moving on there was also another
major realization during this time
period for microsoft
their revenue and stock price had more
or less gone sideways for 15
years the dot-com crash was something
that all tech companies experienced
but unlike microsoft and cisco
innovative tech companies like apple and
amazon were quickly able to grow past
their dot-com highs
the truth is despite the dot-com crash
the tech industry was still swiftly
growing
while microsoft was over here still
making operating systems in their office
suite
just like they were in the 1980s and
1990s
that made sense in the 80s and 90s when
the infrastructure for widespread
computer use was still being established
but by the early 2000s the majority of
the growth within the computer
infrastructure space
was done and the real growth opportunity
ahead
was how the infrastructure was going to
be used here's the thing
the company that builds a road likely
made a lot of money
but the real money long term is made by
the companies
on the side of the road for example take
a look at amazon
in the early 2010s microsoft's market
cap hovered in the low 200 billion
range meanwhile amazon was pulling in
100 billion dollars in revenue
annually by the end of 2015. a similar
case can be made with google
and facebook and alibaba and instagram
and many many more
the computer hardware and os space was
worth hundreds of billions of dollars
which is awesome however the market that
based their businesses
on this technology were worth trillions
if not
tens of trillions satya nadella who
became the ceo of microsoft in 2014
was well aware of this fact and was
determined to change the direction
of microsoft microsoft had already lost
a big in the email space
the search space the e-commerce space
and even the mobile operating system
space
which you would think they would have
easily controlled despite these losses
there was still one blossoming industry
that microsoft had a chance of claiming
and this was the cloud right after satya
nadella became ceo
he ditched microsoft's mobile plans and
all of their other late entry projects
concurrently he also laid out a plan to
slowly phase out large-scale windows
development
in order to primarily focus on
microsoft's cloud products
by the time windows 10 came out in 2015
microsoft's cloud business was starting
to take root
making it clear that cloud deserved even
more attention
as a result microsoft would decide to
launch windows 10 for free
to users who already had windows 7 or 8.
this way microsoft could quickly justify
discontinuing support for these
operating systems
which would allow them to divert this
manpower into their cloud division
in fact microsoft would drop support for
windows 8
just six months after windows 10 came
out no one could really complain
as if these users wanted the latest
updates and security patches
they could simply update to windows 10
for free despite this trend towards free
software within the operating space
microsoft would double down on their
office suite during this time period
microsoft would really focus on
promoting their subscription service for
microsoft office
called office 365. this was in stark
contrast to google
who of course have their free office
suite office 365
did offer consistent updates with the
latest version of word and powerpoint
and such
but it was much more expensive over the
long term coming in at 70
per year here's the thing though the
core audience from microsoft office
is students and professionals and in
most cases
neither students nor professionals are
actually the ones paying for microsoft
office products
it's generally their employer or the
university
thus it made more sense to create a more
constant stream of revenue from these
two markets
and let google for the most part control
the consumer space
today these moves have paid off
massively as microsoft is no longer
dependent on revenue from personal
computing
in fact personal computing is the
smallest portion of their business
and this category also includes revenue
from xbox and microsoft surface so
really
windows operating system related revenue
is a very minor portion of microsoft's
overall business
today concurrently microsoft has grown
to be the second largest cloud player
only beaten out by amazon and microsoft
has
also grown their office products and
linkedin business to account for roughly
one-third of their total revenue
at the end of the day if you haven't
noticed yet there are a variety of valid
reasons microsoft refuses to develop
windows 11
but the main overarching theme is that
microsoft is no longer a consumer
business
yes many of their products are still
used by regular people
in the end however the vast majority of
microsoft's revenue comes from business
to business transactions
whether that be windows licensing to
dell microsoft office licensing to ucla
or cloud infrastructure support for
verizon and
msi plus directly appealing to customers
through a new flashy version of windows
or a cool new microsoft office refresh
is no longer their focus
instead their focus lies in making their
products as simple
and reliable as possible in order to
catch
and retain as many business customers as
possible
over the long term taking a look at
their stock growth
this seems to have worked out
phenomenally so
it's unlikely that microsoft will be
shifting back anytime soon
did you guys realize that microsoft
underwent such a radical change
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys thought this video explained
microsoft's evolution
well and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm ari and i'll see you guys on the
next one